[Music]
hey guys we got a big surprise a
trampoline another pony fake ids it's
even better this year no more back and
forth at christmas we're not doing the
backup no i just said that
but together christmas like a normal
family together christmas
hello grandpa kurt
my dad is going to scoff at everything
we do your father hasn't met the new
evolv dusty i mean who wouldn't be
impressed with you
dear god
this is gonna come off weird dusty but
he's beautiful
why don't you bring the car around i'm
not the driver i'm brad
step dad my dad's coming too
dad that sweater he wears a red sweater
so i can see him in a crowd where's my
big man
[Music]
so this code dad's thing you gotta ask
another man's permission to see your own
kids everything is rock solid between me
and brad hair in fact
best friends really
brad thank you stop it i'm good because
we're boys
[Music]
i don't get the whole girls thing here's
the game plan you want me that one that
she tells you about all of her problems
with the guys she's actually dating it's
called the friend zone no no no the
worst advice anyone could give you you
want to be like brad and be in the
friend zone you want to be like dad and
get in the end zone oh gosh those
piercing eyes like a velociraptor
don't you see what he's up to he thinks
you owe me a harpoon bathroom no i'm not
harboring anything i just want to find
the perfect together christmas tree you
don't think i can operate a chainsaw oh
yeah cut like butter
cut down cell phone tower i think brad's
dead
again daddy don't you want to spend the
holidays the one true real dad brought
him all the way up here just to get back
at me yep you're opening up the harvard
oh the heart was wide open and it's
fleet week this is getting good
we're gonna settle this boys
cut it out this is child abuse don't be
such a snowflake
five more minutes and i get to meet
joseph you throw that we are no longer
co-dads
you're gonna pump fake that thing all
night are you gonna take a shot brad huh
he's never played sports ever what
what maybe it's stuck to his hand
[Applause]
you know what dusty you're not worth
psych you're truly worth it
[Applause]
[Music]
you